[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend was plant russland das ist
nach wie vor die frage angesichts von
mehr als 100.000 russischen soldaten an
der grenze zur ukraine
moskau verlegt kampfjets nach belarus
und lässt atomwaffenfähige
langstreckenrakete
spiele putins während in polen und in
deutschland jetzt die ersten
zusätzlichen us soldaten als verstärkung
der truppen in europa eintrafen wo endet
dass die ukraine bereitet sich auf eine
russische invasion vor demonstrativ an
diesem wochenende in der region von
tschernobyl
von dort berichtet an erfasst
kampfflugzeuge am himmel über belarus er
neues demonstriert russland stärker an
der grenze im norden der keine
15 kilometer entfernt von der grenze
zieht die ukraine nach im kampf um die
bilder
die geisterstadt pripjat nahe dem
atomkraftwerk tschernobyl die
ukrainische nationalgarde hat geladen
militärübungen
fernsehteams aus aller welt ringen um
einen platz in der ersten reihe der
kampf ähnlich verbissen wie der der
nationalrat
auf dem knapp zweistündigen show wird
viel geboten
häuserkampf
verletzten bergung
[Applaus]
spezialtruppen suche
danach minister aufgebot erst der
innenminister
dann der verteidigungsminister mit
beschwichtigung aufrufen die derzeitige
konzentration der russischen truppen in
belarus reiche nicht aus für eine
offensive sagt der unsichere wir haben
absolut keine feindlichen beziehung zu
unseren bella russischen nachbarn wir
pflegen nachbarschaftliche beziehungen
die bälle russen wollen nicht gegen die
ukraine kämpfen und auch wir wollen
nicht gegen sie kämpfen mit ihm
verbringen nachfrage ab solche
veranstaltungen diesen konflikt dann
nicht zusätzlich verschärfen eine medien
hysterie gar erst bevor man mit mops ich
hab meine mutter bat psychiaterin sie
brachte mir vom kind tagen an bei
hysterie und panik einer absage zu
erteilen
also bitte ich alle ruhe zu bewahren und
nicht in panik zu verfallen und ja
einige medien übertreiben das ausmaß der
bedrohung geschieht
doch gegen so eine inszenierung ist
schwer anzukommen
für weitere nachfragen außerhalb des
protokolls steht der minister dann aber
nicht mehr zur verfügung sein abgang
abdruckt die show gelungen und die
unterstützung aus dem westen läuft an
die usa haben truppen geschickt
insgesamt 2.000 soldaten werden in
diesen tagen in europa erwartet ob das
zu einer entspannung des konflikts führt
bleibt fraglich
ja in die diplomatischen bemühungen zur
lösung des konflikts schaltet sich ab
montag intensiver auch die
bundesregierung ein mit einem besuch des
kanzlers in washington und der
außenministerin in kiew die diplomatie
soll die lösung bringt das gilt auch für
einen anderen konflikt in wien geht es
seit monaten um eine wiederbelebung des
atom abkommens mit dem iran dass donald
trump bekanntlich beendet hatte gestern
kündigten die usa sanktions
erleichterungen an dass teheran heute
als richtigen wenn auch nicht
ausreichenden schritt begrüßte die
verhandlungen sind schwierig auch weil
in teheran gefängnissen unschuldige
menschen sitzen mit denen iran eine art
zynische geisel diplomatie treibt kamran
safari an zeigt uns das schicksal der
familie gaddafi
er sitzt seit über zweitausend tagen in
haft kamran gattari im ewin-gefängnis in
teheran wird er festgehalten
hier bilder eines anderen gefangenen der
dort misshandelt wird
januar 2016 der it-experte und
österreichische iranische staatsbürger
für die am flughafen teheran verhaftet
der vorwurf spionage das urteil zehn
jahre haft
wir treffen seine frau erika in wien
kameras geständnisse seien unter folter
entstanden erzählt sie uns ein anzeichen
dafür wann er freigelassen wird um
gruppe freigelassen wird gesundheitlich
geht es im aus schlecht weil wo der
operiert und trägt eine 30 zentimeter
lange prozesse auf seine wirbelsäule und
hat einen tumor und während dem
gefängnis war war das zweimal im konvikt
angesteckt
harry kaka delhi fordert dass die geisel
frage zur bedingung für ein atom deal
mit dem iran gemacht wird hier im wiener
palais coburg versucht der westen seit
monaten teherans atomprogramm
einzudämmen
nicht zulassen dass unsere
familienangehörigen
für den iran ein spielball
an erster stelle muss hier wirklich
verhandelt werden zuerst dass man alle
geiseln frei ist erst dann dann mit
atomgesprächen weiterverhandeln irans
außenamtssprecher hatte zuletzt
offiziell an gefangenenaustausch ins
spiel gebracht dafür sollten westliche
sanktionen fallen die usa haben jetzt
einige sanktionen gegen irans ziviles
atomprogramm gelockert mehr als zwei
dutzend ausländische geiseln und
doppelstaatler die kamera die sitzen im
iran in haft werden von teheran auch als
druckmittel benutzt sagt eine eu
parlamentarierin sind diplomatie hat
system im gottesstaat iran und sogar ein
unschuldige zivilisten immer wieder zum
spielball auch von geopolitischen
machtinteressen des landes das ganze
kennen wir nicht erst seit dem atom deal
sondern spätestens seit 1979 seit wir
diese große geiselnahme in der
us-botschaft haben
1979 nach der erstürmung der
us-botschaft in teheran wurden us
diplomaten 444 tage als geiseln gehalten
perry rosen war einer davon er setzt
sich jetzt für die geiseln ein
der us sondergesandte für iran robert
malley hat mir gesagt dass er kein deal
anstrebe bis nicht alle us geiseln
freigelassen werden
ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer für harry
kkd auch wenn ihr mann österreicher ist
sie hat nur noch einen wunsch ich
vermisse kann man sehe jeden tag und
meine drei kinder vermissen ihn auch
jeden tag in unserem leben fällt da
einfach und am liebsten würde ich mich
freuen wirklich wenn man ihn mit haben
nach hause schicken würde
mit den nachrichten kommen wir jetzt ins
inland gundela deutsche unternehmen
melden infolge der omicron welle massive
personalausfälle laut einer umfrage des
industrie und handelskammertages haben
rund 25 prozent der betriebe erhebliche
engpässe und erwarten eine verschärfung
bis mitte februar besonders betroffen
die bereiche gesundheit und transport
1815 neuinfektionen registrierte das lka
binnen 24 stunden die sieben tage
incidents stieg auf
1388 über lockerungen der chor ohne
regeln wollen die ministerpräsidenten
auf der nächsten bund länder runde
beraten warnen aber vor zu frühen
öffnungen so sagte die
rheinland-pfälzische ministerpräsident
in drei er der rheinischen post zunächst
müsse der für mitte februar erwartete
höhepunkt der omicron welle abgewartet
werden
die synodalen versammlung zur erneuerung
der katholischen kirche in deutschland
ist mit ersten konkreten reformen
beschlüssen zu ende gegangen ein großer
erfolg so der vorsitzende der
bischofskonferenz
das konkrete handeln der kirche werde
verändert gefordert wird dass die
gläubigen stärker an bischofs wahlen
beteiligt werden eine öffnung des
priesteramtes für frauen eine lockerung
des pflichtzölibats
und eine moderne sexualmoral
der frühere us-vizepräsident pence hat
erstmals ex-präsident kramp öffentlich
attackiert und ihm direkt widersprochen
er wies trumps behauptung zurück dass er
das ergebnis der präsidentschaftswahl
vor gut einem jahr hätte kippen können
laut verfassung habe er dazu kein recht
gehabt sagte er auf einer tagung in
florida pence galt lange als loyaler
unterstützer trumps ihm selbst werden
aber auch ambitionen auf eine
präsidentschaftskandidatur
nachgesagt
die flutkatastrophe im vergangenen
sommer hat im aartal
134 todesopfer gefordert die
aufarbeitung warum so viele menschen
sterben mussten läuft nach unter anderem
in einem untersuchungsausschuss des
rheinland pfälzischen landtags
klar ist es gab frühzeitige warnungen
doch sie gingen vielerorts ins leere
wurden nicht ernst genommen oder
erreichten die bevölkerung gar nicht das
mobilfunknetz brach zusammen und sirenen
konnten nicht einspringen viele waren
nach ende des kalten krieges demontiert
worden nun zieht man lehre nicht nur im
aartal zum einen zu zum besseren
bevölkerungsschutz soll künftig auch
wieder die sirenen warnung gehören seine
gehlert berichtet ausländer
schon bald soll überall in landau bei
gefahr dieser wahn ton zu hören sein
seit fünf jahren werden hochmoderne
serien errichtet digital gesteuert und
akku gesichert jetzt liegt es daran die
bürgerinnen und bürger dahin zu erziehen
um zu sagen wenn dieser ton erholt dann
schaltet rundfunkgeräte einschaltet
handys ein
informiert euch bis 1990 holten
bundesweit 80.000 dieser alten sirenen
es wurde regelmäßig geübt nach dem ende
des kalten krieges wurden viele abgebaut
oder funktionieren nicht mehr nicht
jedoch in landau wir brauchen auch
möglichkeiten menschen zu erreichen die
eben nicht übers handy erreichbar werden
mit den
alarmierungs apps wie kartfahren oder
nina sonder die quasi spontan und
schnell die möglichkeit haben müssen
reagieren zu können bei der flut im
aartal fehlten die sirenen selbst die
feuerwehr wurde vom hochwasser
überrascht kein mobilfunk keinen
digitalfunk und kaum sirenen
zum einen sind die weggerissen worden
zum anderen hatten wir ab etwa 19 uhr 30
kompletten stromausfall hier in der
region und die augen tränen sind auch
nicht akku gepuffert das heißt dem
zeitpunkt konnten sie auch gar keine
sonne auslösen die feuerwehren und alle
katastrophenschutzeinheiten waren mit
einer derart katastrophalen lage
überfordert das muss man auch ganz klar
zugestimmt
auch in den ersten tagen nach der flut
ging es den teams für katastrophenschutz
nicht besser keine koordination
mangelhafte organisation
unklare zuständigkeiten
bei einer solchen katastrophe wie haben
beispiel der awo die
die helferinnen und helfer die
katastrophenschutz organisationen aus
ganz deutschland zusammen kommen haben
wir gemerkt in den stäben wir sprechen
nicht überall die gleiche sprache all
die dinge müssen jetzt wieder
bundeseinheitlich organisiert werden
in der flut nacht machte das wasser nur
wenige meter vor der kreisverwaltung
halt im keller die einsatzzentrale des
landkreises ohne jeden überblick ein
sauberes lagebild bekomme ich eben nur
wenig informationen
bekomme und diese dann auch systematisch
aus und bewährte und da das dann die
schlüssel für vernünftige entscheidungen
treffe und das war eben auch nicht der
fall weil es eigentlich in der flug nach
zu keinem zeitpunkt auf keiner ebene ein
übergeordnetes lagebild gab
erst jetzt werden im aartal moderne
serien montiert ein erster schritt zu
spät für die vielen opfer der flut
bei lawinenunglücken sind in österreich
seit gestern neun menschen ums leben
gekommen viele verunglückte waren
außerhalb präparierter pisten unterwegs
so starben nahe der grenze zur schweiz
ins bis am freitag fünf menschen als
eine 400 meter breite lawine sie mitriss
südöstlich von innsbruck kam heute ein
mann ums leben vier verschüttete konnten
nach längerer suche geborgen werden die
wetteraussichten für deutschland sind
wenig winterlich viel regen gibt es
morgen und das anhaltend und kräftig im
nordwesten kommen gewitter dazu trocken
bleibt es nur am alpenrand in der mitte
und im süden gibt es sturm zum teil mit
orkanböen bei drei bis neun grad am
montag muss überall mit schnee und regen
schauern gerechnet werden danach regnet
es nur noch im norden es wird wärmer am
mittwoch 7 bis 12 grad
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
sie lauten ohne gewähr 4 17 19
26 39 45 superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 6
so viel von uns an diesem samstag und
alles vom sport von bundesliga bis hin
zu den olympischen spielen jetzt gleich
im sportstudio mit dunja hayali wartet
schon schönen abend noch bis morgen
[Musik]